i would be mortified if i had a [ __ ] on
a commercial flight
one time i was on a plane there was
about 12 people on the plane it was for
work
one of the people on the plane took a
[ __ ] and took a newspaper in
with him and then brought the newspaper
out and put it back down for other
people to read that's disgusting i'm
sorry
but he [ __ ] and it smelled and he acted
like nothing was happening
and i'm like oh my god if that was me
i'd be so
i'd have to get up in front of everyone
and say listen i had a horrible thing
happen i had to take a [ __ ]
so sorry the whole plane smelled
richard you want a [ __ ] on the plane
yeah there's some weird thing where
when i'm in that bathroom i feel way
safer when the plane's like bouncing up
and down
and i would even go and just sit in
there even if i didn't have to [ __ ] just
because i don't know there's something
about
being in there i felt safer than being
at my seat bouncing up and down
if it was a rough flight do you realize
that makes no sense you
left your seat belt which was securing
you in your seat
to go sit in the bathroom with you
there's no security
i'm not trying to say it makes sense
robin
it just thought for some reason makes me
feel better in there look at that big
dumb smile
on his face how is he working for me i
don't understand who he is
like hillbilly is working for me
but you know what it is i'm not even
painting the proper picture he goes on a
plane he gets so wasted drunk
like i mean not even just a couple of
cocktails but like to the point that he
can't walk they have to take him off in
a wheelchair so he's
drunk he's [ __ ] on the plane he's
not wiping well because he's loaded
and then and anyway and he's still
nervous all the drinking is supposed to
calm him down so he can fly
and then the worst part of all he takes
his shoes off because he's told me this
and he likes to be in his socks so he
walks to the bathroom
in his socks where other people are
shedding
oh yeah
you walked into wet right i did yeah and
i didn't have
extra socks i was like what the hell do
i do you know
he's walking to the bathroom in his
socks like he's in his living room
it's just a douche bag you said somebody
took a newspaper into the bathroom to
[ __ ] sal used to do that
and i saw him go in with and there was
like four people waiting he had taken a
bat
a newspaper into the bathroom and i'd
nobody knew that i knew him so i started
complaining to the other people in line
i was like what the hell's that guy
doing in there
do we need to call somebody well
somebody knock on that door if he was on
my flight i would have opened the
emergency exit and pushed him out
goodbye but then everybody flies out
unfortunately
i don't care they they thank me i know
it
they don't mind dying as long as sal's
off the plane
suck them out through the [ __ ] door
what a dick i'll admit i take
i took a crap on a plane but richard one
time sat in his seat
pissed himself and sat in his piss on
the plane for the entire ride
no because we were taxiing at jfk
for like three hours it was a rush hour
on a friday
yeah and i had to pee and i just they
wouldn't let you get up to use the
bathroom
and i just ended up being in my pants
so someone had to sit in that piss seat
after he left
oh my god what how long was your flight
no defense it was like a three-hour
flight to florida
and you sat in your wet piss yeah
you're like that uh rattle rizzo guy
yeah
on the bus yeah yeah remember he died on
the bus and he was just sitting there
he had already wet himself he hit
himself and then he died
you both should be on a no-fly list i
swear there was a pilot at jfk that
recognized me
and he he literally said to me he goes
richard don't you dare [ __ ] [ __ ] in
my plane
right and i just laughed but he was
serious
yeah they should hang a sign around your
neck violent offender
i want my pilot on a plane to be worried
about flying
not if richard is [ __ ] in the
bathroom i don't need him distracted